محازم صغير يتشعب الحوار وياخذنا الى
محطات في التاريخ
اسست لهذا الحاضر الماساوي الذي نعيشه
والممتد من منتصف الخمسينات في القرن
العشرين وحتى هذا اليوم والذي في اساسه
سببه كما يقول حازم صغير اطاعه الفرص فرص
قيام الدوله الحديثه على يد من كان لديهم
هواجس وطموحات امبراطوريه اذا صح القول
بعد سقوط الامبراطوريه العثمانيه ويعني
بذلك تلك القيادات التي سمحت لها فرص
التاريخ ان تستولي على السلطه
فقفضت فوق الممكن الى طرح الشعارات وحدويه
وتحريريه وقوميه كانت بمجملها نوعا من
التخدير للمجتمع
وبالطبع من يتامل في تلك السنوات الممتده
من ثوره عبد الناصر الى نهايه السبعينات
ومع وصول رجال الدين الى الحكم في ايران
يستنتج امرا واحدا ان كل ما فعلته تلك
الانظمه هو تهديم لفكره الدوله الحديثه
وتاليه تاليه القائد الذي فعل ذلك
والمفارقه ان هذه الانظمه التي تحسب او
كانت تحسب يساريه في ذاك الزمان والاحزاب
المؤيده لها القوميه والمراكسيه
هللت لسقوط ايران في ايادي رجال الدين
يعني انعدام للرؤيه انه النوع من الانظمه
يؤسس لمخاطر في المستقبل لانه يعتمد على
ايديولوجيا
دينيه على وضعيه ممكن الواحد يعني لا
تستطيع ان تناقشها
في تجربه اليسار اللي ايضا انتهت لمحل
كتير شعبوي انتهت بانه المهم تكون انت ضد
امريكا
بس كون ضد امريكا هذا المطلوب هذا
وبنفس الوقت الضمار تراجع البعد التنويري
باليسار مع عدما ديني منار ديني هلا مثلا
ما تبقى من اليسار اللبناني وراء حسن نصر
الله
يعني بغض النظر عن اي مناخ ثقافي اي مناخ
فكري ايديولوجي يشيع وحزب الله بالبلد
فهذا مو مهم بس كمان الى جانب هل تجربه
الضيقه لليسار
مع مع الثوره الايرانيه كيف في اسباب اخرى
من نوع انه
كان في شعور بهالمعسكر العريض اللي بسمي
حاله مناهض للاستعمار او بمناهض
الامبريليه او كذا انه
السادات راح على
روحه
كانت ضربه قاسمه كانت ضربه قاصمه
لهالمعسكر جبهه الصمود والتصدي بعدين اجت
قبلوه قبلوه لهيدا كانت الحرب اللبنانيه
انتهيت واللي انهاها يعني انها ضرب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وحلفاء اللبنانيين هو
النظام السوري يعني صراع داخل البيت
الواحد يعني بمعنى ما كان في شعور
باحباطات متواليه اجت الثوره الايرانيه
لتعطيه لتعطي هالمعسكر شعور بانه لا القوى
المناهضه للامبرياليه بعد قويه قويه
وقادره
لمن هالشي ادى
خروج مصر من من الساحه العربيه
وبنفس الوقت سوريه متورطه بلبنان
فهالشي عمل عطا موقع القيادي بالمنطقه
وكانت وقتها وكان وقت الاتحاد السوفيتي
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه في
الايرانيه لعبت مش بس
بتدبير جزئي للبلدين بتدمير اكبر لعلاقات
الاهليه بين السن والشيعه عبر المنطقه
سريعا ما تم تطييف الصراع وصار الصراع
السني الشيعي غالب على اي صراع تاني يعني
بعدد من البلدان
وبين وما زال حتى الان يعني
مش يعني مش نظريه المؤامره بس الواحد
يتساءل دائما انه هل يعني هل هذه الاحداث
كانت بريئه فقط نتيجه
حميه اذا بدنا نسميها حميه شخصيه او قرار
شخصي من من هذا الزعيم او ذاك للدخول في
حرب يعني مدمره كان في كان في نوع من
الانظمه استولت على المنطقه منذ عبد
الناصر
وهي الانظمه اخذت الناس فوتتهم
بتهليز معتم رهيب
ما له افق الا يهزيمي يا نكبي يا مصيبه
يعني ما له افق
عقلينه لانه اي محاوله خروج عقلاني من
المازق لزعيم حط البلد فيه
بتؤدي اولا لسقوط سلطته
وسقوط مبررات السياسيه والفكريه لسلطته
وفي انهيار ينتج حروب اهليه طبعا طبعا نعم
هي دوامه خلقها المستبد ليدوم ففي صعوده
حول الدوله او البلاد الى سجن او زنزانه
لمعارضي الراي وفي سقوطه حول البلاد الى
حطام والى مقبره جماعيه وهذا ما تعيشه
شعوب هذه الانظمه منذ حوالي سبعين سنه
يعني هاي انظمه هاي انظمه بتخاف
بتخاف من المسقفينها كانوا مثقفين بتخاف
من صحفيين لانه بيكتبوا بتخاف
بتحط ايدها
بتخاف من جيشها
بتخاف من جيشك تعمل له اجهزه تقليد قديم
من ايام الثوره البلشفيه بروسيا لينين جيب
مفوضين سياسيين يقفوا فوق راس الضباط
النزيه للجيش
صدام حسين عمل الحرز الجمهوري بايران
عاملين
نظام بيخاف من كل شيء بخاف من كل شيء
لشعور عميق بانه هو غير شرعي مغتصب سلطه
الشعب ومغتصب الشعب
هيدا النظام بيعمل الناس
اولا بصدقوا الاشاعات لانه ما بيعرفوا
السيسي بتسود الوشايه بالثقافه العامه
بيسود خوف الناس من بعض قله ثقتها ببعض
في كتاب كتير حلو
لامريكيه اسمها
عن سوريا اسمه
غبوضات اذا بجوز نجمع غموض غموضات السيطره
تحكي كيف انه مثل ما بتذكر بعدي كيف انه
الكلام بين السوريين بايام حافظ الاسد صار
قايم على فكره كما لو ان يعني بنحكي بنقول
مثلا حافظ الاسد بطل تحرير فلسطين كلنا
بنعرف انه هذا الحكي كذب بس كنا بنتصرف
كانه صح كما لو انه مزبوط
مجتمعات مرضيه بالضبط هيك او مثل ما كان
عمكيه كتب عن العراق كتبوا الشهير جمهوريه
الخوف كيف العراق ايام صدام كان كله كذب
كله
فصام بالاخر القمر
تقول بتقول حازم انه بالعوده الى فكره
الثورات انه الثورات هي تصنعها المدن اما
الارياف قد تصنع الحروب الاهليه بمعنى
يعني انا فهمت كحسب ما فهمت هذا القول انه
الارياف في دائما بتصدر بتصدر للاحزاب
الاحزاب اللي هي تتزعم السلطه احيانا
بتصدر هذا الكم من الناس والفقراء اذا صح
القول يعني الاقل بيدار واحد يقول من
الشيء اللي بعرفه انه
الثورات الفلاحيه انتجت
الصين كبوديه فيتنام الى اخره انتجت واحد
من اثنين يا انتجت انظمه مستبده
المدن هي اللي تنتج ثورات ولا سيما
بالمعنى جديد للثورات يعني
ثوره على الاقل يعني
بمعناها اللي اضافيته ثورات اوروبا الوسطى
ثورات اوروبا الوسطى والشرقيه اللي اسقطت
عمليا الانظمه الشيوعيه هاي الثورات اضافت
كثيره معاني لكلمه ثوره كلمه ثوره
تعرفها بالف طريقه يعني في ناس بيعرفوها
انه طبقه تسقط طبقه في يعني
الثوره
الاوروبيه الشرقيه والوسطى هي اولا سلميه
قايمه على حركه او تحرك المجتمع المديني
المدني
ما في زعيم ما في ديولوجيا ما في عقيده ما
في حزب مركزي هذا كل هالمعاني هيدي معاني
مدينيه صعب تكون معاني
لسبب بتحس انه اذا انتقلت ركيزه الثوره من
المدينه للريف فهذا اشاره لانه الثوره
انتكست واخذت
ممكن يطلع وهذا ما حدث في الربيع العربي
صحيح صحيح
[موسيقى]
وهذا اخر كتاب طلع اللي هو مجموعه مقالات
طلعندر جديد
مره في لبنان
وهيدا مقالات كمان مقالات اطول شوي من
مقالات حدثت مره
هيدا المشرق العربيه طالعه عن رياض الرئيس
اكبر كتاب
ضخم طالع ممكن استخدامه حجر الضرب
ايه انه
الراي في كتير جامع شي جامع بين الافكار
السياسيه السائده
هو الروماتيكيه الروماتيكيه بمعنى توليد
الفكره من فكره مش من احتكاك
يعني
اذا استعملنا لغه فرويد
مبدا اللذي بيغلب على مبدا الواقع
فشي بتقدر تقشر له باللغه السياسيه
المتداوله بالسلوك السياسي بالتجارب نفسها
[موسيقى]
بالاهداف اللي بتنحط اللي
مقطوعه الصله تقريبا بالقدرات القائمه
الفعليه
بتغليب الحركه نفسها على الانجاز يعني انه
فينا نقول الحلم بشيء يستحيل تحقيقه الحلم
بالشيء الذي يستحيل تحقيقه وعدم الاهتمام
بالتحقيق
يعني مثلا
زعيم سياسي بيفشل ما بهمنا انه فشل ضل
بنضل نحبه ونسمنه تسمين رفيع وعالي والى
اخره لانجاز ما يقعد
كان يرغب ان كان يرغب كان عنده فيما لو
كان هون كان يرغب كان عنده كل الهوايه
الحسنه والاستعدادات والبطوله والكذا والى
اخره بس ما مشي الحال
هاي يعني
[موسيقى]
في محطات اساسيه بالتاريخ الحديث تبعنا
فيها شيء بيتكلم صحيح
نعم قد تكون النوايا حسنه عند بعض
القيادات في بداياتها الاولى لذلك
يبرر لها دائما ان ترتكب المزيد من
الاخطاء والمزيد من التسلط بناء على ان
هذا القائد او ذاك كان يرغب ان يشيع على
العدل بين الناس ويحقق التنميه ويشيع حريه
التعبير لكن الظروف لم تسمح هناك اولويات
وهناك مؤامرات تستدعي الانصراف الى صددها
وتدميرها وهذا ما حدث ويحدث دائما ويتوالى
بشكل ماساوي
ولعل ما حدث في الثورات او في الربيع
العربي هو اكبر دليل على الارتكابات التي
قامت بها هذه الانظمه عندما بدات بقتل
الناس العزل
وتناوبت في هذا الفتك المرعب مع قوى اخرى
هي التيارات الاصوليه التي قدمت كبديل عن
نظام خرجت من رحمه ترى بدقه القول ان هذه
الاصوليات هي فرق جاهزه يفرج عنها في
الوقت المناسب او انها صناعه مخابراتيه
غربيه وما شابه ذلك من تقديرات وتفسير
في مجتمع طلع من جوفه
كل قوى الموجوده في كل قوى المعبره عنه
بعجرها وبجرها بمنيحه وبعاطلها
لكن كان في بصمات
نقص الحريه
نقص تقليد الحريه تقليد الحريه كتير ضعيفه
في المجتمعاتنا
وضعف ضعف البيئه المدينيه اللي ممكن تكون
رافعه
تحول حديث او او عصري تحول عصري فوري حديث
فالقوى الاخرى الاكثر تقليديه الاكثر
محافظه الاكثر
اللي علاقتها بفكره التغيير علاقه مضروبه
اصلا هي مالها كتير مع التغيير او هي مع
مع محافظه
تعاكس المحافظه القائمه بس هي ما بدها
تغيرت هي اللي طلعت واللي كان مبين
بحركتها وبشلوكها بصمات فقدان الحريه
بتجربتها
فقدان صلتها بالسياسه يعني اول ملاحظه
بتلاحظها على اذا بتاخد حكي لاخويا
المسلمين مثلا بس تقرا نص اخواني او تشوف
سلوك اخواني او اول شيء بجيك بخسر على
اللي ما بيعرف شو السياسي
فممكن يخبط خبط عشوائي يعني يعمل اي شيء
صح
فهي انا بستبعد مني من القائلين بانه
مؤامره فلان بس في مجتمع ما عم تقدر
الحريه تقلع فيه ما عم تقدر المبادره
الذاتيه يتقلع فيه المسؤوليه فكره
المسؤوليه ما عم تقدر تقلع فيه في انظمه
تقمع بس تعمل تنميه
انقلاب بينوشين تشيلي انقلاب
كتير
انقلاب ضد نظام ديمقراطي وقام حكم عسكري
جائر وراسي وهي
بس اقتصاديه
في انظمه هلا حاليا مثلا نموذج صيني
الشهير
نموذج الصيني ما في حريته عمليات حزب واحد
بس في تنمي بس في تحول اقتصادي كبير
هاي الانظمه العسكريه بالمنطقه عنا هي
مثل ما عنوان شهير انجليزي لا خبز ولا
حريه
يعني فقدان الامرين يعني
معنى العيش يعني استعمار حياتك بالكامل
استعمار حركتك وسلوكك وكذا ومش بس هذا ما
بكفي ليوصفه لانه هيدا نظام بيقدر يقيم
معك بالبيت
يقيم معك بالبيت من خلال اشياء كثيره من
خلال التلفزيون من خلال
التعليم الكتب المدرسيه تبع اولادك
واحيانا مثل ما
ستاسي بالمانيا الشرقيه كنت تعمل او صدام
حسين ويمكن حافظ الاسد
احيانا تحويل الاولاد لو شات على الاهل من
موقع حرص النظام على اهله
انه بدنا شويه تعاون معكم حتى اهلنا يضلوا
على الصراط المستقيمين يعني ما يغلطوا
يعني شيء مرعب فهيدي انظمه انظمه كامله
احاطه بالشخص
احدهم بيقول النظام القمعي هو مش بس
اللي بيستولي عليك
بحياتك اليوميه هو اللي بيستولى عليك
باحلامك بالحق كوابيس بالاحلام
[موسيقى]
بالعوده حازم لتجربتك طبعا انت
امتحنت الاحزاب القوميه بشكل عام يعني من
داخلها ومنخارجها وكتبت فيها يعني كتبت
الكثير
وقراءات ربما تكون الاكثر عمقا لانك على
درايه بالتفاصيل فيها اكثر من سواك اذا
اردنا يعني الاشاره الى ايجابيات في هذه
التجارب
القليله في الكتب في التنظير
والى ايجابيات ايضا اسست عندك بعض الاسئله
الخاصه ربما
فينا نشير الى شيء
اي تجربه باخر الامر ممكن تغني
اللي تتعلم الذي يخوض بده يتعلم يعني انا
بدي انه في عدد كبير من الناس بعضهم
بعرفهم شخصيا بعضهم
اكبر اللي فيك تقدرهم
ماكينه حياته اخذتها المسارات
الاسي والتجارب المعاهد فيها معاناه وهي
لو اتيح للمجتمعات تبعنا تكون مستقره اكثر
لو اتيح يكون في فكر ليبرالي اقوى
بمجتمعاتنا ما فيها شيء هذا التقليد موجود
يعني ضعيف
فبضطر اضطرروا ناس مثلي وهن كثار
بالمناسبه انهم يفوتوا بتجارب
ممكن تحطمهن في البعض تحطموا بالتجارب
يعني بس كمان
فيك تحكي عن حياه اعداد اكبر كتير
كان حظهم اشواق
كان حزن اسوا
وتفعه غالي
اذا بدك بالمحصله العامه لا لو بلا هكر
احسن يعني
نعم نعم لا هو بالاخر كما ذكرت انه
المرور بهذه التجارب ومش نقيصه بالنسبه
لحياه الشخص بالعكس يضيف في هي بحث عن شيء
يعني في قول شهير
لساره اظن انه من يبلغ العشرين وممكن يكون
عنده تجربه باليسار يكون بالعقل واللي
يصير عمره خمسه وتلاتين وبيبقى داخل هذه
المنظومه بيكون بصير ايضا بالعقل
يعني هون بدنا نقول انه اذا بدك
كونك لبناني كان بمعنى ما امتياز
كل امتياز لانه تعيش ببلد سحريه كان يسمح
لك جرب صحيح بتطلع من التجربه بتعلم شغله
او شغلتين
للاسف الشديد بمجتمعات اخرى حكموها العسكر
والامن مكه متاح لالك تعمل هيك يعني
اذا تعلمت من التجربه
فيستحسن تنسى علمك تنسى ما تعلمته او تطلع
من البلد لحتى تقول هالشيء تقول تعلمت
منها التجربه بس اذا بدك تعبر عن اللي
تعلمته انت بالبلد فالعرض سلامتك
بهالمعنى الواحد كمان بحس بدين
لبنان التقليدي عليه لبنان القديم
على كل نواقص وقشور وما اخذ المحقق عليه
يعني بحس بدين هذا اللبنان على تشكل اي
وعي
لابناء جيلي انا صحيح
[موسيقى]
فيما يشبه السيره كتاب قديم نسبيا لحازم
صغير يروي فيه عن تجربته وعن تاثيراته
وانحيازاته
لكنه يقيم جردت حساب مع تلك المرحله التي
كانت مختبرا اذا صح القول للافكار
في حلقه اخيره قادمه مع حازم صغيرا يحاول
استكمال قراءته للتجارب الحزبيه والسياسيه
التي دمرت مجتمعاتها وبالتالي لمساره
الخاص كاتبا في الفكر السياسي وصاحب رايي
في الصحافه العربيه
[موسيقى]